you are in the world this is pi data
chicago's virtual meetup
i'll start with a couple of
introductions my name is rebecca berway
i'm one of the new co-organizers of this
meetup
and i'm joining sue chang and ji who
have been organizing this meetup for
for some time now before we start i'd
like to
thank our major sponsor num focus num
focus is a non-profit organization
that supports and promotes development
and adoption of open source scientific
software
many well-known python libraries are
supported and maintained by num focus
they provide funding and community
support to software projects
including but not limited to jupiter
pandas matplotlib numpy scipy
julia and desk in turn num focus is
supported by several large companies
including ibm microsoft and intel
okay su chang if you want to hit record
now
i'm going to introduce serge okay see
that we're recording
so for tonight i'm very pleased to
introduce our speaker today
serge masis a little bit of background
about him
serge masis has been at the confluence
of the internet application development
and analytics for the last two decades
currently he's a data scientist
at sygenta a leading agribusiness
company with a mission to improve global
food security
before that role he co-founded a search
engine startup
incubated by harvard innovation labs
serge is passionate about
providing the often missing link between
data and decision making
his book titled interpretable machine
learning with python
is scheduled to be released in early
2021
by uk-based publisher pact
so today serge will be talking about
interpretable machine learning with
python
if you have any questions during the
talk feel free to put them in the chat
and i'll go through all of them at the
end of the talk i'll read them in the
order that they were received
and finally for the duration of the talk
we'll ask you that you remain on mute
so that's easier for everyone to hear
the speaker
okay handing it off to you now serge
thank you so much for the
introduction um i i i was gonna start
with the introduction i didn't know
uh you were gonna introduce me so i'm no
no it's not really
needed anymore but basically this is the
gist of it you know
um and so now like a few people
before the presentation or maybe it was
only one and i'm just adding some other
person
um asked about how to get started with
the workshop um
it's fairly simple there's a link it's
in the chat
there's a more complicated way which i
don't recommend which is
cloning the the github
but you know if you know if that's what
you want to do then go ahead and do it
but
uh you can just go to the this link and
this link will take you to the very
complicated
uh colab link which is this one up here
um and then as you see here
you have three steps that once you click
on this link
i'd like you to do so that you know
uh you don't have to do it later and
it'll be a lot quicker
um it should take less than a minute but
you know who knows um so
um if once you get to this page um
this collab page all you have to do is
go to
you know step one
you know hit on that and then step two
just put it on cue and then
step 3.1 and there we go
that's that's all you have to do and
then i'll go back to the slides right
now
and you can follow me with
the the non-practical part of the the
presentation
before the workshop so i can explain
what we're gonna do and also a little
bit
about uh you know what is machine
learning interpretation and how it can
be useful
so the first part of this is
why do we need machine learning in
interpretation
and it's needed because machine learning
by itself
is an incomplete solution and this is
kind of something that might kind of jar
you a little bit to see it this way but
the reality is
like uh you know simple problems
you can pretty much put them in into uh
you know a procedural programming
uh of some sort you know and uh
you they're pretty much deterministic in
nature so
you know they're simple the solution
pretty much covers all of it
but the problems we solve with machine
learning are you know
are complex problems and we have to
optimize as much as possible
so they're never entirely complete
so by explaining the decisions model we
can cover those gaps
of our understanding of the problem it's
in completeness
uh one of the most significant issues
that we face
in machine learning is given the high
accuracy of
our solutions we tend to increase our
confidence levels
to the point that we actually think that
we fully understand the problem
then we are misled into thinking that
our solution covers all of it
which is not true you know otherwise you
know we've been toting like
a hundred percent like with no decimal
points anywhere
you know uh accuracy all the time and
that's not the case
um so uh what is it useful for
um you know once you you know how to
model
not only how it performs but its inner
workings you can understand how to place
guardrails
to make models more reliable and safe
and
and know when and how they're wrong and
how how can they be tricked um
you can also mitigate bias to find out
if your model discriminates or makes
incorrect associations between the
features that can be
proved quite problematic and then lastly
just simply for knowledge discovery you
know models can simply be used to
understand your data
and the phenomena they depict you learn
a lot from them and you interpret them
and and this
that is the form of interpretation we
will have in this workshop but you keep
in mind that they can be used
for the liability for safety and uh for
fairness
as well okay so
why does it matter i mean uh there's
there's this institute called
ai now and they've been creating yearly
reports since 2006
which reveal how ai is perceived by the
general public
problems caused by ai systems have been
causing major public relations blunders
i mean i don't think i have to tell you
what's been happening since 2006
as i mean 2016 i mean uh but
it's increasingly causing distrust and
it's
uh it's fueled by a countability gap in
ai systems
as well as poor regulation uh
surrounding this
uh these technologies um this this comes
to the detriment of companies that
monetize on these technologies
as well as the public that could benefit
er er you know from from either these
technologies or even better ones
should we not distrust them um
and and you know these these of course
come from accountability gap
so um when when we talk about
accountability we have to talk about
human decision making
and human decision making is flawed
no doubt but a human can second guess
their decisions
based on the reasoning and ultimately
they're accountable for any mistakes
uh when we discuss a machine learning
model's decision
we generally focus on the very last step
inference
and that's when a model has already been
deployed
and it's being used in real-world
applications however
decisions were made before that not by a
model by by a human
and because of this there's potential
for bias in every single step
and and what i mean there is you know
what problem part of the problem are you
focusing on
what data are you using how are you
preparing the data
what model classes are you using how
what evaluation
metrics do you use and how to deploy the
model
there are indeed many untraceable
decisions that were made before
and not communicated or not even
understood
that create this accountability gap
so how do we fix it okay so
the pillars of machine learning
interpretation are
fairness accountability and transparency
i mean you you expect a machine learning
model
to produce fair predictions that are
unbiased they must be traceable back to
something
or someone and should be able to
understand how exactly they were made
many people think this cannot be done
with a black box model
but we we first have to understand what
this means
um so that leads to discussion
of what is a white box and what is a
black box model
so a trained white box model
can can reveal intrinsic parameters such
as a mathematical formula
weights a tree or coefficients that can
be easily
understood these simple mechanisms make
them interpretable
with very little effort on the other
hand
a black box model
is not as impenetrable as you would
think it's just
much more complex it's this complexity
that gives it
an edge performance wise but it also
makes it less interpretable
but it's by no means impossible after
all we can explain
exactly how human brain makes a choice
yet we often trust its decisions because
we can ask a human for the reasoning
after the fact
and of course this this process isn't
perfect
but we can approximate it and that's why
we call it interpretation
we don't call it explanation uh for that
reason
i mean although interpret we can explain
an interpretation
and we can get caught up in the
semantics there but
that's exactly what we need to learn do
with the model
in the second part of this workshop so
now we'll begin part two uh which is
about
interpretation uh methods
but first a disclaimer and some details
um i hate to disappoint you i know this
is called pi data but this is not a
programming workshop
you're not expected to be a pandas ninja
hell even though there's python code
involved
you're not even expected to be a python
charmer either
so what if if if this is not a
programming workshop
what is it exactly
an interpretation workshop of course
therefore please run every code
sell as instructed during the workshop i
won't explain
the code line by line you can figure
this out
later guided by your comment by the
comments
and please to resist the urge to do this
during the workshop
what i will explain what is in described
in the annotations
which tell you what the code will do or
did already
as well as the output i interpret so
basically
the output is the most important part so
pay attention to that
uh secondly the annotations and lastly
the code in the comments those for the
purpose of this workshop don't don't
really matter
i mean as i said it's not that it's not
important
to learn how to code these things
absolutely it is because
you know if you're going to apply it in
your own work
or as a hobby or something you have to
know how to write the code
but it's not the most important part the
most important part
is what is generated by that code
so now let me explain the data
you know um there there is a real
group of people there there there's a
manhattan chocolate society
um and they've been meeting since 2007
for the sole purpose of tasting and
judging fine chocolate
to educate consumers and inspire
chocolate makers to produce
higher quality uh chocolate that that is
their
their goal uh since then they have
compiled
a data set of over 2 200 chocolate bars
from
all over the world rated by their
members
this rating is derived from a rubric
that factors things like aroma
appearance texture flavor aftertaste
and overall opinion and bars rated
are are most mostly darker chocolate
bars since the aim is appreciating the
flavors of cacao
in addition to the rating the manhattan
chocolate society dataset
includes many characteristics such as
the country where the cocoa bean was
farmed
how many ingredients the bar has if it
includes salt or not
and the words used to describe the bar
so um we're going to start with the
mission to make this fun
i believe like you know when we're
facing a data problem it's important to
frame it in terms of a business problem
um you know for the purpose of this uh
workshop we'll call that a mission
um so a chocolate manufacturer let's say
has reached out to you
eighty percent of the bars are highly
rated um
everywhere uh by critics but a handful
of them
are consistently not and and
a handful of those uh sales are bad for
them too
for some of them uh which suggests that
the public doesn't like them either
um in focus groups though people seem to
like them
regardless of expert opinions
so um there's a dissonance there you
know i have
you have critics that you know don't
like them but
you don't necessarily trust just the
critics and the focus groups they seem
to like it
but people won't buy them anyway so
they want to leverage this data because
this data is from
professional expert slash critics it's
not from professional expert slash
critics i mean
but knowledgeable lovers of chocolate
which means they they they're not like
snobby about it they they
they just judge them you know with with
just their taste they're not necessarily
uh doing it for a living or anything
like that so
they ask you to build models with the
data and then compare one of their
outstanding bars with one of their
disappointing ones
so they can see uh you know what does
that model
what do those models tell you about
those bars
and then maybe understand you know kind
of reverse engineer what
you know what people are thinking a
little bit
and and how that data you know what are
the qualities of the chocolate
that that correlate with that
so this is approach uh we're we're gonna
train classification models um and
and we're we're we're gonna focus on the
highly recommended and outstanding
uh because that's that's really what
they like all their chocolates to be
and then we're gonna we're gonna apply a
little bit of global interpretation
to see what are the the features that
push a chocolate bar to those to those
levels
and then we're going to also use local
interpretation
and and we're going to use local
interpretation for
the to separate what makes a bar
outstanding
versus what makes it disappointing and
uh and we're gonna use
uh both the nlp and the tabular data for
that
and uh and we'll get to that during the
workshop but
uh this this data it has a bunch of
tabular data
as well as sentences just text um
and and we're going to use that as well
oh hold on that's not for now all right
so
um we'll begin so uh
i'll i'll give you a second to go back
to
this uh back to this um
google colab and then we'll continue
from
this point forward uh 3.2
all right well hopefully everybody's on
board
um so let's let's take a peek into the
data
all right so here you can see most of
the data
is is numerical um
you have the company which we will
discard we're not really interested
in the company there's so many different
companies
and uh it's really hard to work with um
with the features that are such high
cardinality
and uh so we're we're going to focus on
all the rest of them
and they've already been uh encoded
categorically encoded so
you can see ones like uh the location of
the com
the company if it's in the canada france
other usa or uk um
the country where the the beans you know
the
came from the coffee bean and the coffee
beans cocoa beans
and you see as well separated by country
and then you also see here
how many ingredients they have and if it
includes cocoa butter
vanilla lectin salt and sugar
and here's the rating this is this is uh
you know what we're going to derive the
target feature from and
over here all of these over here these
are binary features that were
kind of already pre-extracted from the
sentences that are here
so if these sentences include the word
creamy
or fruit or intense it will it will have
a one
instead of a zero basically um
and this one it says object because as i
said it's
they're just sentences or phrases
uh with mostly adjectives so
um here we can take a look
just to kind of see uh what it shows us
i said the company the review the the
date
the year of the review uh how much
a percentage of cocoa it has what the
rating is
how many ingredients uh if it includes
these uh these ingredients um
the location of the country you know
where the
where the chocolate bar was manufactured
and where the cocoa came from et cetera
et cetera it goes all the way to the end
where indeed you see here's tastes
so there's so many different things that
we could do to explore the data but
you know we're not going to do all of
them right now we're just going to focus
a little bit
on the target variable which is ratings
so we want to see how it's distributed
and as you can see here um
this is kind of like the cutoff point
over here you got 3.5
and there's nothing over four i guess
nobody
has ever gotten like uh no no bari has
ever got a 5.0
or a 4.5 it kind of ends at four
um so they they are kind of uh uh
you know very exclusive about that i
guess so
we're gonna only since this is a
classification model what we're going to
do we're going to
take everything above 3.5 including 3.5
and and that's going to be a 1 which
signifies
highly rated and then everything below
it
not highly rated or i think highly
recommended it's the word i'm using
um so uh now that we've already done
that we've taken a look of that
where we're going to set a random seed
for and that's that's an important step
to do just simply for
representability uh especially when
you're
we're going to split the data and i want
it to be consistent
so i'm going to set that then we're
going to
train test split we're going to we're
going to
take our data and we're going to split
into two parts
a train training set and a a test set
and we're going to do it 33 versus
67. oh another thing that's important
here this is where
we took our rating and we we said okay
well
everything above uh three point or or
equal to 3.5 is one
and everything below is a zero
uh we also have to do the same as you
see here for
our our our features we're removing
tastes we're removing company uh but we
want to use the taste
for our nlp models so um
we're we're gonna create a separate um
you know uh x type train and x test
but for this these nlp models
um another important step precisely for
nlp is you know it's not like we can
feed the model
all this all these sentences and i'll
make sense of them
uh we have to vectorize them and
uh and one good way of vectorizing them
is
is to uh this this method called uh term
frequency
inverse document frequency so we're
we're going to use that one
um and i'll show you what i mean in a
second
what it what it does with that if you
haven't worked with this before um
all right so this is this is a sample of
what that means
so here you got a phrase that says
raspberry nut
oil oily caramel um these are
these are like uh the this is what it
generated
and basically relates to how frequent
the the the term is in relation to
the whole uh set of of sentences
and uh so uh which is in this case
a corpus if you will so we have these
sentences
uh or or phrases and this is how
frequent it is
in relation to the entire amount and
within the
the its own uh phrase and
well we don't expect these to be uh
to to show up very often or or be
repeated within the same phrase but
it does show you how frequent they are
in general
so um obviously
it's there there are 416 different words
in this corpus and uh you know only
three or four
show up per phrase and uh
the model's supposed to make sense of
this and so
um i'm not going to discuss that any
further
because it's a it's a pretty broad topic
but
basically it's what we're creating here
is a a sparse
uh uh a sparse matrix which is then fed
to the model it's 416 columns wide
times two thousand and two hundred
uh give or take um
so you're just gonna have to trust me on
this one and and run this cell this is
just simply a a cell that all it does is
evaluate a model um and
and and plot uh uh roc
auc curve so um
now we're gonna train first our tab uh
our tabular model um and then we're
gonna
train our nlp model and uh
the the the three steps we're gonna take
for the
this these uh this training these models
are first we initialize the model
then we fit it and then we evaluate it
so
that's basically what these three things
do here so
i'm just going to hit
that
so here it shows us some metrics what's
important to note here is that
uh this line here it's the coin toss
line in other words it's if
if what you saw is above it consistently
and it is
it's it's an okay model i wouldn't say
it's
amazing it's not uh you know it's not
great
but it's for for the purpose of this
of this um workshop for what we're doing
it it's quite good because uh basically
we're just
pretty much trying to find the
connection
between high ratings and uh
and features of the chocolate bars
and this is the nlp model um
well one thing i should note is that uh
the
the tabular model is an um support
vector classification model
and um the nlp one is a light
jbm
so now we get to the part where i'm
gonna explain
uh shap uh this part will take a while
so what i'm going to ask you to do is
while i explain chap you run these two
cells
and then i'll come back and i'll explain
what these two cells were doing
so again just trust me on this um i'll
explain it
um this time and just run them
and uh it's gonna take up you know
three minutes so while those three
minutes go on
um i'll be explaining chap
so to this to first describe what chap
is i have to explain
what shapely values are um
and shapely values are
are derived from game theory
um so specifically coalitional game
theory
and that might bring a bell if if you've
ever seen a brilliant mind and
and heard about uh dr nash
but um it's it's very fascinating theory
uh
well not that this one was the one he
was working on but um
yeah uh coalitional game theory uh
is like the theoretical foundation for
shapely values and shapely values
is what chat is based off
so i i'm going to explain this through a
basketball analogy
so imagine you're blindfolded at a
basketball game
uh a loudspeaker announces when a
player exit or enters a game by their
number
but you don't know what the who the
player is um
the say it could be michael jordan
or say it could be mr bing
there could be good players there could
be
bad players and you know they could hop
in
and hop out at any time you know you
you get the announcement but you
wouldn't know uh
you know you know who they are the only
way
you can tell if they're any good is if
their presence make a difference in the
score
which the large speaker would also tell
you
you know when the score changed so
with this you can get an idea of
basically you know
which players are good and bad so for
instance
you could notice you know when when
23 is playing score increases a lot
regardless of who else is playing and
this can really inform
uh you know your idea of
who are the best players and and this
difference of scores is called
a marginal contribution um so
once you run through all the possible
permutations
of players in the court let's say this
this game
lasts forever you know um
we you know we basically call these
coalitions you know
like each different set of players
is called a coalition so you can
calculate the average marginal
contributions of each player
within each uh contribution you know and
you average it out and this is called
the shapely value
you know when whenever you've you've run
through these permutations and average
them out
for for a model the features are the
players
um different subsets of the pleachers
are the coalitions
difference in the predictive error are
marginal contributions
and of course you're blindfolded because
the model is a black box
or tweet is as such you don't know for a
fact
you know exactly how the inner workings
are in the model
uh all you're doing is predicting based
on on what you're inputting and what's
coming out
so problem is computing
shapely values is very time consuming as
you can imagine you have to run through
all the different permutations of
features
and and so shapely
additive explanation also known as shap
combines it with other
methods to to approximate shapely values
or it does a lot of sampling and and
different techniques to kind of cut
on the computation time but but it does
this while adhering to its mathematical
principles
and it has some very good principles uh
which
which is why it's it's it's considered
uh
you know a very good method
yeah so now it's done and
basically as many explainers go
when you're interpreting models you you
first
there's first the part where you're
initializing an explainer
and uh well first i should probably
explain what explainer is
uh basically an explainer is um
you know loosely uh for for all these
different methods
some kind of um object or class that
that it's all sole purpose is to be able
to take in a model
and and be often reused
to for for the purpose of explaining the
model so
you know sometimes they have different
requirements in this case
uh shap has a requirement uh in the case
of a kernel explainer of getting some
kind of
background data so i'm not going to get
into the code too much
but i'm i'm your your basically what the
cell is doing
is feeding some background data and also
telling it what the predict function
of the model is so then it can go ahead
later on in doing some explanations
so then the next step is to fit the
explainer
and it does this to to specific data
and so we're going to fit it to
the the test data so that's what it's
doing here
again i'm not going to go into too many
details so what the code does
but once it has those features it
can generate whatever it's going to
generate in the case of chap is going to
generate chap values
as i said chap values are like shapely
values
but they're approximation
so once we've done that we can do
something with it
and in this case we can produce a
summary plot so
the summa prod these the chap tummy
products are really cool because they
can
through the color coding they can
explain so many different things on so
many different dimensions
so if you read it from top to bottom
you get which features are overall most
important in the model
in other words which features are the
top predictors to for
for a uh for a chocolate bar to be
considered highly rated and you see here
that
uh the percent of cocoa in the chocolate
bar
is the most important feature
and if you read it from this middle line
outwards you can tell which ones are
you know positive correlated or
negatively correlated
so that's also an important dimension to
take in account
that you have features that correlate
positively
with highly rated and also negative
rating but you also
something you'll notice is that every
every feature will have
points most in in both
sides so that's where the other thing
comes into account which is
the feature value so each feature
has high and low values
and for binary ones they're only have
you know ones and zeros so the the blue
the blue colors will represent the zeros
and the red ones
will represent the ones so you know like
for instance that sweet
if it tastes sweet whenever it tastes
sweet
it's highly correlated
negatively it's negatively correlated um
towards you know being highly uh you
know highly recommended
so that's that's a bad feature to have
um and then there's ones that are not
there that are continuous
like cocara percentage and something you
can tell is that there's a sweet spot
and and you you see between the blue and
the red
there's purple and you see a lot of
purple
to the right of the line which
suggests that that's the sweet spot
you know somewhere in the middle there's
a there's a there's
values um of you know percentage
you know maybe 70 or 75 percent uh
and that's the sweet pot that's what
people like when you get above that
they tend to not like it you know and
when you go below
you know all these blue dots they're
kind of scattered
it's unclear um and that's we'll talk
about that a bit later but that's where
interactions come along you know when
when you see
some of the same values across both
parts it's
it's it means that there's some other
features that are actually weighing in
so um like for instance you see here
review date
and you see that um you know
there's the blue ones tend to be on the
negative side so
it that to you to would suggest that
uh you know earlier years they're
probably harsher
with their with their rating as they
became
later on they became more lenient it
seems to suggest that but there might be
other factors
so uh you you take all these things with
a little bit with a grain of salt
there's they're not as
clear-cut as you would think um but
some of them might be and and that's
where another thing comes into account
which is
how separate things are sometimes
especially with these binary features
you'll see
you know like uh the reds entirely to
the right and the the blues entirely to
the left
and and and that that will indicate
how much it's weighing
in the model in general um and that
brings me to the next point which is
how wide things are so here you see a
lot of things here
a lot of wideness and that really tells
you
that there are a lot of features kind of
clustered there there's a lot of feature
observations in that area so
uh the chat values indicate
that that they tend to be clustered
around there so
that that also tells you some dimension
of distribution
of how many are there um
and then in other cases you see that
they're spread out so a lot of the
observations are spread out in these
kinds
so it means that across um you know for
taste cocoa
if it tastes like cocoa it they they
tend to be
highly correlated but they're highly
correlated in different
um you know in different amounts
you know like some are more than others
so um now that we've taken a stab to a
global interpretation
let's explain local interpretation a
little bit um
i think so
for this one uh this is
this is something called the decision
plot and the decision plot
basically will tell you uh
how do you arrive a certain decision and
you start you start in this case we have
several several different observations
for the same
uh for the same french manufacturer and
they all start
here at the middle line that middle line
is is
what you call the expected value and in
this case is
somewhere around 37 so that
if you think about it intuitively you
know that being highly rated
there's like a 37 percent chance of
being highly ready from the get-go
so that's like the starting point so you
see that
all these tend to kind of start there
and then
features individual features push you in
one direction another
so you start at an origin which is there
and then you you kind of all these
decisions move you in one direction or
another
and uh that's that's how you end up
uh in in a certain decision in this case
we're highlighting false negatives so so
those false negatives
will are are these dotted lines here
so you kind of start to understand why
are they false negatives in this case
you realize that they're false negatives
because their
country of being origin or other is
weighing on them in that direction a lot
so they're kind of pushed in that
direction in
in in being classified it's not highly
recommended because of a country of
being origin
being other and it's not clear what the
country origin was
but the model seems to think that's a
bad thing
so here's another one
another decision plot and this is for a
specific bar
and when you're looking at an individual
one it's going to show you
all the different uh values that it has
specifically which is kind of neat i'm
not going to get into detail about this
one because i just noticed
we're a bit delayed in terms of time so
um
you can read this in uh later but it's
it's basically a very neat feature that
it has
for looking doing local interpretation
to
groups of of of observations
so now we're going to go to look at
what we call our instances of interest
which are the two
bars that i spoke of one that's
outstanding and one that's disappointing
so uh basically what this code does
is put them side by side so we can look
at both
and and what their values are so we have
um
their ratings one has a 4.0 another one
has a 2.75
um they're it's they're both
too too positive or too negative in
other words they were
they weren't misclassified um so which
is a good thing you don't
you want to make sure your model
classifies them correctly because
otherwise
you know would you trust what it's
telling you about the model if
it's not classifying them correctly so
um here you see it's highlighting by
yellow the ones that are different
one of them has country of being
original other
another one it has venezuela as where
the bean came from
one of them tastes earthy another one
tastes
berry so that's basically the difference
between both
so um so now let's use the force plots
to explain the instances of interest
which are these two
so you can see that taste berry is is a
good feature
and to have if if you have it as one
and also the 70 percent cocoa seems to
be
right on target maybe it's that sweet
spot we were talking about
um review date being 2013
it seems to be a good thing and the fact
that it was manufactured in france
is a good thing other hand counts of
ingredients
four seems to be weighing in on that
side
so you have to kind of realize that red
for force plots is is like the positive
force and blue
is the negative one and they're kind of
meeting in the middle well not quite in
the middle but they're meeting
at whatever they predicted it would be
in this
case is 0.75 78 percent
probable that it is highly recommended
for this one you see that it's 0.26
percent
i don't know in other words 26 probable
that it is um highly recommended and
what's weighing in that
is the fact that it's it tastes earthy
honestly that doesn't sound very uh
appetizing um and then country origin
other
seems to be a bad thing and lectin and
the fact that it has
four ingredients so um
now that we've looked at that let's
quickly
i'm going to quickly explain what uh
lime is and then we're just going to do
an exercise with lime and then i'll try
to wrap things up so we can go to
questions
so basically
lime stands for local interpretable
model agnostic explanations
yeah you provide it with an instance of
interest which is
in this case this right bread
you know right bread cross and then
it makes predictions for points around
it which we call the neighborhood
so these points don't necessarily exist
in your your data set their
perturbations
uh which is why the neighborhood is also
called the perturbation space
then it trades a circuit model around
these points
but these points are weighted which is
why you see some
you know are bigger than others
and and it's done in accordance to how
close they are to your
point of interest so what you're trying
to understand here
is that why this point is here you know
what what is the decision boundary
between these and other ones
so this line that you see here is the
decision boundary
and and and the point of line uh
training this circuit model
is not to get to train a certain model
just simply to
to extract the coefficients and uh so
what what the coefficients is what
determines the the
decision boundary on a local level so
what what it's
basically arriving to is a weighted
sparse linear model
and then extracts the coefficients the
coefficients
is it's what you'll see is basically
what tells you what is more important or
not
so let's go through an example of that
so we're going to do the same thing
we've done before which is
initialized in explainer uh
and then we're going to fit fit the
explainer to an instance
and and approves a summary for it
so here you see this is this is what it
arrived to these are the coefficients
and it tells you what each feature
weighs into
the decision so um in this case the
orange is good the blue is bad
um so you see now highly recommended 78
percent
and and why because the cocoa percentage
is greater or equal to 70 percent it
tastes like berry
it doesn't taste like sweet it doesn't
taste like sour it doesn't taste like
molasses
and then on the other hand the fact that
it doesn't taste like cocoa
seems to be weighing on the other side
so that's how
it explains things um
we can do the same for the other one
and um this is what we arrive to um
the it's basically the same as before
but you you start to realize
okay it there's there's the fact that
it tastes earthy it's not it's not
showing up there but you have other
things that
that way in the fact that it the cocoa
percentage
is is less than 70 percent is less or
equal to 70 percent is a good thing but
the fact that tastebury equals zero
taste cocoa equals zero it doesn't like
all of these because it doesn't include
them
um so now
now let's get to uh we'll we'll quickly
do this one
and then we'll go to questions
unfortunately we're not gonna have time
to go through
the entire nlp stuff but at least we'll
do this one
um so the text explainer is very similar
to the
um to the to the tabular explainer
you just uh initialize it but unlike the
tower explainer we must create
a pipeline because the reason we must
create a pipeline is simply to vectorize
the stuff where we're going to put in
we're going to
feed it the the data we're gonna where
we're gonna use and the data we're gonna
use is text so
the pipeline just vectorizes the data um
and then we we also fit the explainer to
the instance
and uh and in this case we're
we're using the the text that number
five has
um which is our outstanding
instance so it likes the fact that
includes caramel
it doesn't like the fact that it it it
says it's oily
and that's why it ends up with a 57
chance that it is highly rated
this on the other hand has two positive
two negative words and two positive ones
seems to like the fact that it
it tastes woody and it says choco but
it doesn't like the fact that it tastes
earthy and burnt
not surprisingly the these these are not
good words to be used
in the context of chocolate um
so uh hopefully you guys
uh learned something with this there is
more here
um and in these bonus sections
and you can continue this
um and and learn from it there's
there's uh explanations for each one and
at the end
there's also some documentation
uh if you want to learn more if you want
to connect to it
later on you can and
i think now it's time for questions um
great thank you so much serge that was a
whirlwind
yeah i hope i didn't rush to the end i'm
so sorry
um but um yeah
oh no problem there's always ways that
people could go deeper
so i'll definitely be coming back to
these plots yeah we just have a handful
of questions so the timing is great
um the first one is from zitzelha
and they ask what is review date in the
data set
oh it's it's just when the
when the the people gathered in the
chocolate in the manhattan chocolate or
what was it manhattan
chocolate society to um
to review the chocolate bar it's just
the year that happened
the year that they reviewed the
chocolate yeah great
and then i also wanted to give you the
comments that people are posting so
rose said super cool and this was i
think when you had just finished um the
local or the global
shapely plots hugo
cheat asked will we have access to the
slides
yeah okay great um if you want
i can put the link in the chat if you
like
i wasn't sure if you wanted to share
that and then deepa asked
the presentation today focused on svm
does this approach work
with other black box models yeah
yeah yeah um like
these the kernel explainer is the most
model and gnostic of shapes explainer
and it will work with any model
as long as you use a predict function
so you just can use any arbitrary
predictive function
from any model and it will work of
course there
there's a few like you have to look into
documentation sometimes there's some
adjustments to make
for it to kind of work correctly
because it expects things in a certain
format but you can handle that
um as far as lime lime has
several kinds of explainers it has one
for tabular data
has one for text data which is another
one we use
and it has ones for image as well
chap also deals with images as well um
but again it's a question of
reading documentation and and and
looking at the differences
but yeah um svms
you know you are also very versatile
model class which you can use with in
many different use cases as well
great just a couple more questions
rolled in
so taylor stanley is asking why
is there no taste earthy feature
explanation in cell 24
which one is cell 24
um
oh okay i think i see what yeah
um that's another thing that's that's a
problem that lime has
um it's not exactly consistent a lot of
these things
even though you do make the best effort
to make them
um reproducible and everything
um lime trains a local surrogate model
and sometimes you'll run it and it'll
say one thing and sometimes another
another another possible reason and i
have to look into it
um oh yeah now it says taste earthy
equals zero equals one and it's it's a
negative
but um yeah that that must have been the
reason
the reason was you'll run it once and it
says one thing you run it again it'll
say another thing
um because it's training a local model
and and there's
and it's doing permutations so there's
there's a
there's a randomness to it and because
of that randomness you won't
always get the exact result especially
when we're talking of such
um you know sparse features
and and this model has it if you had
features that were less sparse
you know like um you know and by sparse
i mean
not all those zeros um if you look at
this
this data set there's a lot of zeros all
over the place and
and the fact that that's the case it
might not find
a connection between a feature a
predictor feature
and uh and and what it's trying to
predict
which is basically the point of it um
so partially that has to do with the
randomness
and partially has to do with the nature
of the data
great next jj asks do you typically
start with feature importance from a
tree classifier
and then transition to chef
um you could but the
the problem is i don't i don't i like to
use the feature important
for for some of the the three
classifiers
but i wouldn't recommend all of them um
because they're the the problem with it
is they're using their own intrinsic
parameters
so there's some bias in that um and
because
of the way they work they they don't
have a certain amount of consistency
so if you want consistent results if you
want something you can
trust a little bit more i would go i go
directly to shop
um you it's it's actually the other way
around i
i would you kind of want to validate it
a little bit with the tree classifier
um feature importance but
i would trust shap a lot more than the
tree classifier
um because precisely because of the
the lack of consistency you find i mean
for instance actually boost has three
different kinds of ways of calculating
future importance
so which ones you should you trust and
when and how i mean
that's something there might be a
perfect answer to it but only you would
know because of the nature of the data
and the nature and the way you train
that model
got it just i'm going to cut it off just
two more questions since this
is becoming a bit of a whirlwind of
questions but they're great
so pablo tercero asks uh super
interesting
you made a simplifying assumption of not
using company name
would ha having the numerous company
names as features
dilute the explanatory power of shop or
lime
yeah yeah they would have because there
are hundreds of them
and um some of them have only
you know one chocolate bar others have
six or seven or 20.
i mean um
if we had a bigger data set it might
make sense to do that
but 2200 and um
yeah it's it's also the sort of call
that that i did with
with uh country like if you notice there
was
a country group being called other
and originally that's 50 different
countries
that were in the original data set but
they became other
and some of them might have good ratings
some of them have might have mostly bad
ones
and uh and the reality is when you're
that's that just comes to show you the
sort of decisions that are done during
data engineering that then affect the
model um
so uh
what's the what's the best way of doing
it i mean it really depends on your
problem
uh for this i didn't put like too much
care into choosing
uh you know okay let's make sure that
all the countries are represented in one
way or another i mean there'd be
different ways if you
truly wanted to represent each one you
might
you might want to represent them by
their average rating or something that
actually connects to the target
um rather than actually make
binary you know you know do some
categorical encoding for each one
because that indeed is going to dilute
the explanatory power
last question jj asks
when in presence of many variables i
imagine would
one may want to consider using rfe check
the confusion matrix results
and then transition to shap any thoughts
yeah yeah you you might want to do that
that that is a good point um
i i have i wouldn't have used it for
this
necessarily this problem um
but it it is an interesting point and i
would
i would recommend it for for as part of
a pipeline where you
you wanted to regulate rigorously and
analyze
um a lot of features uh it could be a
good approach
great um and then i'm just gonna close
it off
excuse me with a final comment from
taylor stanley
awesome thank you very much and great
presentation
thanks thank you everybody
and that concludes our meetup uh just
one minute over
lots of things in the chat if you want
to check it out serge
um and and we've posted the slides in
the google collab
okay great thanks everybody
bye have a nice evening have a good
night